but for whatever reason none of these
cases have ever been solved when you
fall in a lake no one cares all we can
do is gas it's a little fun to guess
it's not fun to get thrown in the lake
and it's not fun to be killed but it's
kind of a little fun to guess there
should be a game called bodies in the
lake and it'd be like a board game where
you you know you end up in the lake and
then they spin the spinner and you go
okay why is the body in the lake and you
have to for a minute give a convincing
explanation of why the body is in the
lake it could be they got drunk it could
be serial killer it could be smiley face
Killers it could be a secret government
program it could be religious cult I
mean you have to then come up with it
could be like X love or scoring it could
be like guy who was secretly gay who's
going to meet with a gay guy on Grindr
but that gay guy was really a serial
killer maybe he wasn't even gay when you
it lands the spinner will land on you
and then you have to give an explanation
of why the binder would be a board game
called bodies in the lake